i mean i would love it if there was like
a coherent cohesive let's say mitt
romney-led
uh faction of the republican party that
was like a counterweight to trumpism but
i feel like their hopes have been
dropping every month since 2016. right
but i think the point is that's because
they don't have power right again these
people were used to the idea that they
were the natural
people to run the republican party and
they got pushed out by this new trumpet
side so they weren't used to the idea
that they had to organize themselves in
order to protect their own interests and
again that's where that's what they
needed to be doing the day after trump
was elected just being against trump is
not enough right that's what voter and
just saying we want to go back to the
way things are
is not enough because voters don't want
to go back to the thing the way things
were they don't want a restoration of
the assad regime right and that's where
again i think there's been a failure of
ideas on that side
[Music]
this week on forward we welcome
political science professor at johns
hopkins senior fellow at the niskanen
center uh author of several fascinating
books including never trump revolt of
the conservative elites stephen tellis
joins us welcome steven thank you for
having me andrew it's great to have you
and uh i i'm a fan of your work i
feel like in this gaming center might be
the most relevant think tank
uh to what i've been working on for
quite some time i cite your research all
the time maybe not yours individually
since they're a bunch of people there
yeah how would you
how like people have heard of johns
hopkins so they're like okay political
science professor johns hopkins they get
how would you describe the niskanen
center
so the niskanen center is a somewhat
complicated operation to explain i often
explain it as
synthesizing things people think are
contradictions right so a lot of the
people who
founded the niskanen center uh had been
libertarians had been the cato institute
had been at the mercatus center
and uh for various reasons uh decided
that um that sort of libertarian brand
was inconsistent with their own
evolution
in part on things like climate change
but also on the importance of social
insurance and redistribution
um that they decided that uh sort of
pure form libertarianism uh didn't work
and so i think what the scanning center
is really trying to do
is to synthesize a belief in the
importance of markets and of creative
destruction
but also with the uh the necessity both
to stabilize capitalism of having
redistribution and
uh to have a proper sort of regulatory
or tax system to deal with exactly the
externalities things that like on like
environmental damage so that's really
the balance that we're trying to
maintain at the niskanen center wow is
there a catchy name for this new
balanced uh vision of libertarianism
because i have to say i probably
subscribe to it
yeah so
so brit lindsey and i
for a long time ran a dinner series in
dc
called the libertarian uh round table um
and so liberaltarian
which is a term that brink came up with
sort of synthesizes that idea of modern
liberalism and libertarianism now the
problem is libertarianism doesn't
exactly right you know
tongue um i i describe myself as a
liberal but in the sense of being in the
tradition of
john locke and jon stewart mill and
john maynard keynes right that's a kind
of tradition that's bigger than our
current left-right divisions and so
liberals find with me so long as people
understand that there's a difference
between that and whatever the democratic
party happens to be doing so are you
describing that as classic liberal
because i hear that a lot about like for
example justin amash yeah i mean well
now justin amash i mean he he's just a
straight-up libertarian libertarian yeah
i know um i mean i think the closest
thing people might be familiar with is
just the economist magazine if you look
at the
um you know that that sort of spirit of
liberalism of believing in markets
believing
in free speech
and the importance of knowledge and the
development of knowledge um but then
also being concerned about the ways that
that kind of liberal commitments can be
inconsistent or can be sort of
self-liquidating in practice um in
particular because markets create you
know so much disruption that if you
don't find a way to uh to stabilize them
then politically they'll be
unsustainable i think that's a classic
kind of liberal problem a problem that
goes all the way back again to jon
stewart mill and you see that in um
in places like the economist so that's
probably the one that um that most sort
of uh will have a resonance for your
listeners if you read the economist then
you are
uh niskanen center left libertarian
libertarian whatever it is that uh we're
going to call this though i will say i'm
going to do some more work on trying to
find a catchy name because i think this
is a very important synthesis
if you reflect on it for a moment
climate change is going to need the
government to help i think most people
recognize that and then if you even
believe in the power markets you would
still need the government to
put in like a carbon credit system or
whatever it was that would allow the
markets to address
negative externalities and in that case
it's a negative externality that could
get the best of all of us i had the
sense that climate change was one of the
major forces that drove this uh the
founding of the niskanen center because
you were looking at it being like okay
the government needs to do something on
this well i think i mean i would say a
couple of things um one i would say both
the climate change thing and this point
about the importance of social insurance
which obviously you know i believe
someone told me once that you have a big
program for redistribution yeah yeah
right
the the universal basic income i mean
that's we we cited niskanen center
research because you were one of the
only places that produced robust studies
on what like a basic income would do so
so i would say you know the guy who runs
our social welfare program sam hammond
who you probably
know of read a great paper called the
free market welfare state and he said
look in practice if you look at the
societies that have the freest
um most deregulated markets
they don't accidentally also have
the largest welfare states those things
in practice
go together right you might be able to
write something theoretically in which
you could simultaneously have a small
welfare state and a um and a vibrant
market society but those things don't
seem in practice to go together and i
think those two
insights are really the thing that
creates the niskanen
synthesis now the other thing i would
say that i think that we have in common
with you and we have different than
people who call themselves centrists
is that people who call themselves
centrists often have these little tiny
tweaky
nudgy sorts of reforms that they're in
favor of and i think what both the
scanning center and you have in common
is the sense that we need
really big large-scale changes not just
tweaks at the margin um famously and
lampedusa's book the leopard he says for
everything to stay the same everything
has to change and i think that's sort of
our
insight that we have in common is that
we need really big changes not just
another tiny tax credit um that's gonna
you know that's gonna be able to do the
work that we need to make this system
stable and just sign me up really i you
know i i do think that we need huge
changes and it's something i struggle
with about what you'd consider
generally moderate or centrist because
that does sound like oh i just want to
tweak things a little bit it's like no i
actually think we're kind of
doomed unless we do some big things uh
though what's interesting and we can
discuss this is that um i've concluded
that the only way to do big things is to
unite uh people uh who right now are
considered moderate i suppose and many
milieus
to try and
reform the system so that we can
actually
get
anything meaningful done much less big
things done you co wrote a book that was
very well regarded i was going to say it
you know massively influential there is
now an ongoing effort around it called
the captured economy which i think is a
fantastic metaphor i mean it's not even
a metaphor it's pretty much literally
true
at this point
can you describe uh four listeners what
you meant by the captured economy yeah
so the basic insight of the captured
economy is that
we have two
big
general problems right one is we've had
a slowing down of economic growth and
all kinds of things that we care about
are connected to economic growth right
the
availability of good well-paying jobs
the availability technologies that can
make people's lives better and at the
same time as we've had that slowing down
of economic growth we've also had an
explosion of economic inequality and if
you look at the sort of classic text
that people wrote decades ago
these two things should not go together
right usually people think if you go all
the way back to um you know the famous
book uh equality and efficiency by um by
arthur oaken he said that there was a
trade-off there was what he called the
big trade-off between equality and
efficiency uh but somehow that trade-off
seems no longer to hold right we've got
we've got both we've got slowing down a
growth and we have an explosion of
inequality and so the question is how
could we have both of those things at
the same time and so the captured
economy either metaphor or description
or whatever we're calling it is our
effort to make sense of that and
essentially what we say is we've had an
explosion
of what economists called rents
on uh various different kinds of
barriers to entry and other kind of
regulatory constraints but that all seem
to have the effect of pulling income
upward right in the book we use we take
we take a bunch of examples but they're
by no means exhaustive
in finance we've had an explosion of
various different kinds of rents that
have in fact led to a kind of
financialization of the economy
we've had an explosion of intellectual
property
which again also has the effect of
slowing down growth because it makes it
harder
for people to share technologies to uh
to use things that other people have
invented put it into new kinds of
products instead we've got all these
transaction costs anytime anyone wants
to do something they have to go and go
through this incredible ip
maze we have had an enormous explosion
in occupational licensing at the same
time as we've had a decline in
unionization over the last
40 years and that's made it harder to
come up with new
kinds of business models and health care
and other things while also pushing up
the wages of doctors in particular and
finally and again if i you know if
you're in new york but lots of your
listeners are in san francisco and other
places
we've had this complete breakdown of the
system of building new housing
especially in places that are of the
where there's the most economic growth
and opportunity and what that's meant is
one that we can't actually move people
where the opportunity is
and that has all kind of economic growth
uh effects but also what it means is the
people who are already the insiders in
the housing system systematically get
their housing wealth pushed up and so in
all those dimensions we have this
enormous
regulatory mechanism for upward
redistribution that also reduces
economic dynamism i i agree with all of
the issues that you just cited um i i
suggested at different times say we
should lighten up on some of these
license share requirements
um particularly around healthcare which
you cite
and one of my jokes was do we really
think human anatomy changes between
vermont and massachusetts
like what's that about
well the other thing about this one so
the example i often use is dentistry um
because you know we all have something
against dentists um but if you look at
the regulation of dentistry one of the
big areas in that is what are called
scope of practice regulations which is
who can do what procedure and so again a
lot of you have had the experience of
going into the dentist office and the
first person you meet is the dental
hygienist and she goes and cleans your
teeth and looks at things and does the
x-rays and does everything else and at
some point the dentist kind of comes in
and sort of waves his hand over
something stays there for two minutes
and then leaves right um but that dental
hygienist in almost every state has to
practice in a dentist's office right
they're required by law right now you
could imagine amazing new business
models where the debt where the dental
hygienists basically say no we want to
go and practice on our own we're going
to go and clean people's teeth we could
do it way cheaper than if you had to
have this dentist
involved right and we wouldn't have to
kick up all of our profits up to the
dentist so you can see that mechanism
there of upward redistribution in this
case redistribution from the from the
the patient to the dental hygienist to
the dentist right and you get that
reduction in economic growth because you
don't have the opportunities for all
kinds of new ways to
to provide
models for how you can practice and you
see that all over
healthcare where you have all these
regulations of who can do what
you know what we don't invest enough in
our sleep if we're sleeping well we're
ready to take things on and if we're not
sleeping well the reverse is true too
ford is sponsored by helix sleep a
premium tailored mattress company that
will send you the mattress of your
dreams based on a personalized quiz you
tell them what your body type is the
firmness and many many other variables
and they will send you the best mattress
of your life they will even give you a
hundred day risk-free trial that's right
you could be an oddball and sleep on a
mattress for 99 days and then return it
i don't recommend it it's not very nice
don't just listen to me gq wired say
that helix sleep is the number one
premium mattress for people who are
looking for a way to sleep better if you
go right now helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com
yang with helix better sleep can start
for you and yours right now
so let's say i agree with you i think
people listening uh agree that there
must be at least some
regulations that
are counterproductive
so you write this book a number of years
ago and then there's an ongoing um
effort i believe called the captured
economy that grew out of the the book
has there been any progress have there
been any victories in terms of
uh trying to
untie some of these
red tape regs and who uh
who
backs those kinds of things because you
can see clearly um that there's going to
be a powerful lobby in a lot of these
um instances where like the
dentists in this case or the healthcare
practitioners say like oh no like we
need to to make it so that you need
certain environments certain licenses
and on one level you're like sure but on
the flip side and i i will say this is
actually something i'm very passionate
about there's a massive freaking doctor
shortage in this country and you look at
it and you're like wait a minute is
there a shortage of human beings that
want to be doctors definitely not
uh so what is the holdup and the hold up
is that there is an artificial cap on
supply
from the uh the physician lobby um and
if you wanted to open a new med school
it's like impossible to do so right now
you know if you wanted to train more
doctors you couldn't and so
by the way our population continues to
grow and so you have a country that has
massive primary care deserts
uh you know there are some environments
you have to drive like two or three
hours just to see a physician
and so at that point the logical thing
to do would be like hey maybe we should
have like physicians assistants or nurse
practitioners able to see people and do
a bunch of things in these areas and the
physicians lobby still fights that
so
you you have
um these powerful lobbies on one side
who's on the other side so okay so
there's a million things all in that uh
and let me unpack them right one thing
to say is if you look just sort of
scanning even further back if you look
at the changes over the last 40 years in
the economy and i think some of this
does explain
the sort of trumpist populist kind of
stuff right which is
um people who have ordinary jobs have
been
uh subject and i i'm basically a free
trader but they've been subject to
enormous
international trade right so um they're
both both through immigration and
through
products right so those people say oh
you know look i i'm in the i'm in the
global economy right my salary is
determined in some significant way by
flows of people and goods
internationally but almost all these
areas that you were talking about are
not right doctors are not subject to
international trade they're not subject
to right we have all these barriers to
doctors who are trained in other places
practicing in the united states doctors
can also determine their own domestic
competition for the reasons you talked
about by limits on
on the training of new doctors and so
there i think part of what we get what
produces populism is the sense that the
people on the top are manipulating the
rules to protect themselves while
everybody else is subject to a different
set of rules and so that's one of the
big
pieces
here and again i think you're right on
the politics the politics of almost all
these sectors is that there's a classic
concentrated interest around the
regulatory regime and just going back to
dentists because i'm obsessed with
dentists um the uh in all these cases
you have a state dental board
right uh and they're the ones who set up
the regulations they determine whether
or not you can do teeth whitening in the
mall or whether you do it have to do it
in a dentist office
now who do you imagine shows up for
dental board meetings
right do you show up for dental board
meetings does anybody you know show up
for dental board meetings unless you
have a friend who's a dentist no
right the people who show up for the
dental board meetings are dentists right
who shows up again in a very different
way who shows up at zoning meetings of
small towns in connecticut and other
places right it's people who already own
houses and don't want new houses built
right not the people who haven't even
necessarily thought of living in the
place where a new development is right
and those so again the basic classic
public choice story here
is that you have concentrated interest
around the status quo
and you have diffuse interest around um
the uh any alternative so you ask me you
know just does this ever change and the
truth and the answer is yes occasionally
it does change right it changes
when somehow the um you know the what i
think of as like the eye of sauron uh
of the large republic somehow gets
focused on this previously
concentrated insulated um uh political
regulatory regime right but the
advantage again so the news right
there's a scandal the news starts paying
attention to it um sometimes this
happens when uh outside investors
philanthropists decide to put a lot of
money into
um building up an alternative policy
domain and that's one of the things we
do at the niskanen center is trying to
provide new forms of information you see
this in the indy movement which i'm sure
you're familiar with the yes in my
backyard movement when um suddenly all
these other people who are renters start
showing up at zoning board meetings and
saying yes we want to
we want to build um and one of the
examples we've used at the skin and that
we did
worked on that sam hammond worked on was
hearing aids right um right now the
hearing aid the existing hearing aid aid
industry and the people around it um
you know want to make sure that you have
to do this in a audiologist's office
right but most people don't actually
need that they could actually go into
cvs and buy
new much cheaper
hearing aids and so that was an area
where elizabeth warren who we often
think of as being classically on the
left
was aligned with with a lot of
libertarians and people like the
niskanen center on that and so all the
reforms in this era almost necessarily
going to have this weird
strange bedfellows coalition often
between people on the left between free
marketers right and those are the kind
of coalitions you need but it's hard for
that i have sauron to pay attention to
more than one thing at a time right um
what the people who are the uh taking
advantage of these captured economy
systems um uh count on is that there's
only one of those things that people can
focus on at the time yeah i think the
iosauron is um getting dumber too for
what it's worth
so it's like looking all over the place
now it's like you know staring at some
social media controversy instead of
something that actually
impacts people's lives um one industry
that this made me think of and this i
guess it's fairly consistent with the um
domains we're talking about uh i spoke
to a guy who started
1-800 contacts
and
i don't know if you know the story but
there were rules on the books in the
majority of states where
only eye doctors could sell you contact
lenses and i actually lived a version of
this because i wear contact lenses and i
could only get them from my eye doctor
and it was very confusing to me and and
whatnot so it took him years
of going to washington personally being
like this makes zero sense like people
want to be able to order contact lenses
you know like a refill online uh he told
me he literally took um i think he's
either dozens or hundreds of trips to
washington he became just like this mr
smith figure like railing against like
the this strange
capture of uh of contact lens retail
um and i heard this and i was like wow
um
thank goodness for this guy uh but but
then i thought like this must also be
the case in lots of other niches that
we don't
experience every day but with someone's
rent-seeking someone like has a hold of
it yeah some i mean so one thing that i
often
try to i often criticize people who are
sometimes sympathetic with us
is they think oh yeah the problem here
is that the big guy is like crushing the
little guy
and that's true in some of these areas
but sometimes the problem is the little
guy keeping the big guy out right so you
think about people who are trying to
sell
glasses directly to consumers and do
eye exams on your phone right warby
parker places like that
well their competition are all these
little
optometrists who want to um do things in
their office right and you see that in
other areas you see that in
uh in funeral services right where
you've got a regulatory regime that's
sort of artificially i want to be able
to bury my
uh loved ones online no i'm kidding
why is walmart not coming in why is
amazon not coming into that sector right
because there's she has anybody who's
ever you know buried a loved one knows
the cost of these things is absolutely
extraordinary right but the um
essentially there right the undertaker
sort of lobby has lobbied states to
prevent competition from larger more
consolidated
industries right so in some cases the
creative destruction would come in by
having large firms come in and compete
you think about the way that grocery
delivery in new york competes with you
know with bodegas right if walmart sold
coffins they'd be like a hundred dollars
what is it cheaper funerals every day so
is is it the case that those
those funeral homes uh
like ha like have made it so that states
have said no one else can actually enter
that industry yeah they have all kind of
regulations about exactly like who can
um who can bury somebody who can put
someone in a casket who can do
all the other things um such that it's
very hard for anybody other than the
incumbents to actually provide the
service and again another thing is
anyone who's ever buried a loved one
knows is exactly the time
when you know any other thing you'd be
haggling or asking but it feels
inappropriate when you're buried you
don't want to go and be like hey i want
to you know
do this funeral for less or whatever i
mean like it feels like you
must honor your loved one properly and
that there's only one way to do so right
but i mean these are just again when you
when you go through it right the
examples of this just keeps multiplying
right so the other example we don't deal
with in the book but we could have
is the sale of cars right so tesla has
you know gotten had a lot of trouble
selling their cars directly to consumers
setting up their own dealerships because
in most states we have franchise laws
that say that cars have to be sold on
through
you know
individual separate dealers right um and
that also is another one that ends up
protecting incumbents right so if you
look at the top one percent there's a
lot of car dealers in that uh in that
one percent and it's really unclear that
any of them are actually providing
anything of value except that they're
skimming off profit right i think a lot
of the car the car companies especially
new car companies would much rather set
up their own dealers their own
um uh their own maintenance everything
else themselves rather than have to work
with a whole
you know
a broken up separate set of dealers as
well and you could just keep multiplying
these examples
of where our regulatory regime
artificially fractures um the market in
that way prevents competition by locking
in a bunch of small
small providers the captured economy
indeed is there any um
cause for
optimism or hope is there something
that's about to for example flip um
because people have just gotten fed up
with a particular
uh
industry cabal so i wish and again i i
think i think the umbi example is an
interesting one right because that's a
again has that classic structure of what
we've been talking about
but one thing is you know that just the
idea and i say in this canon we do sort
of two things right we drop these big
truth bombs from 50 000 feet where we
create these large synthetic things like
the captured economy book that helped
give people a name for a problem that
they were sort of vaguely aware of and
then they can actually name it and
describe a structure to it
and then the other thing we do is we do
a lot of
what's called legislative subsidy where
we sit down
with members of congress or legislators
and we try and explain to them because
usually it's only the incumbents who
have the information
to be able to explain even the
regulatory regime that the legislatures
are in charge of so i listened to your
podcast with my friend and co-author lee
drutman and he was talking about this
about that's what lobbyists do right
lobbyists have
information and so long as they have a
monopoly on information it's really hard
to challenge the status quo so i think
so the mbs are a good example right
where they're showing up right so one
thing they're doing is they're sort of
shining the light on where
these arrangements are happening they're
showing that there's a larger diffused
public who's actually mobilized and in
many cases they're bringing
information to bear where previously
only the incumbents had
information so just really quickly one
example of this is um there are some
great studies of this process that show
that you know who shows up at these
zoning board meetings in little towns
it's often like retired lawyers who have
the time to sit around studying the
zoning regs right and they tell
their um uh their city council members
whoever oh this would be terrible this
won't be legal right well in fact
actually you could do it but you need
somebody else in the room to provide
alternative sources of information i
think you see that across the board in
these areas when you get even just a
little bit of counter information in the
room
that can often change the politics of
these things quite dramatically right
but the nature of these things is again
that the incumbents are organized and
the challengers are disorganized and you
need something to throw at them and one
of those things you can throw at them is
you know our parties right parties
conceivably can be a big enough interest
to change how these these issues are
seen but also there's other ways to you
know in particular through philanthropy
and other things to create counter
sources of information
and now a word from our sponsor better
help we all get down in the dumps
sometimes whether it's family
relationships work stress the state of
the world and we all have our coping
mechanisms for me it's trying to get
outside it's getting some exercise
but sometimes we need something more
sometimes we need actual help help
i first saw a therapist when i was a
teenager and benefited from it
tremendously have sworn by it ever since
and i actually have family members who
work directly in mental health so this
is something i believe in very very
deeply better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat only therapy sessions so you don't
have to see someone if you don't want to
you know face to face it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours our listeners at forward
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
yang that's betterh-e-l-p-com
yang
[Music]
so i spoke to lee recently uh even after
that podcast that you spoke of and lee
is convinced that
uh the two-party system is a major
problem obviously wrote a book called
the two-party doom loop and thinks that
the u.s should have
four or five or six national parties um
i obviously as you probably know i agree
with him um but before we we get to to
you've written a number of things on
this topic um most recently it was this
book
uh never trump the revolt of the
conservative elites where do you see the
energy
of conservatives who are not trump fans
going right now
yeah so
and again i think all these things we're
talking about are actually in fact all
mixed up or connected you mean well
connected i don't mean mixed i don't
mean mixed up in a bad way i mean
they're all like intertwined yeah
they're all actually the same
thing so i remember right after the
election right after the election i
decided my sort of war work when trump
was elected was i was going to join the
niskanen center right it was time to get
off the sidelines and these seemed like
people who were actually
might actually have some influence on
the
on the republican side and that they
that seemed like a wholesome set of
people to get involved with
and i was critical that so much of their
activity
ended up going into various forms of
democracy reform or rules changes or
whether other things whereas what they
really needed to do
was to get involved right they needed in
the in the terms of this essay we called
the futurist faction which was drawn
from the conclusion of never trump um
you know if they really want to have an
influence in the future of the
republican party they were not going to
be the ones running the party anymore
right but you could imagine a world in
which they had a coherent faction that a
dominant trumpet faction had to
negotiate with and that that in fact was
the more common pattern in american
history if you go back into how our
parties were organized for most of our
history
they were actually sort of loose
confederations
of these um smaller factions which is
which were coherent which were organized
you think about you know the democratic
party of the 1930s right it's a
coalition of
unions often quite radical unions in the
midwest in the northeast right and
southern segregationists
right that's what the party was right
the republican party was its own kind of
weird coalition between um between
progressives and liberals and stalwart
business businessword republicans and
that's true all the way back in american
history that that's what parties are and
so a lot of the problem i think
is that that factional structure is
broken down we've gotten parties that
are too coherent
and in an interesting way one of the
first people to really challenge that is
on the left if you look at the dsa
people over in brooklyn right um that
you probably see in like hip bars and
stuff um you know they are creating a
faction they're out there they're
creating their own magazines their own
um meetups and bars they have their own
systems of funding candidates of
recruiting candidates of mobilizing
people they're connecting people
laterally
the analog was the tea party really and
then the tea party elected a ton of reps
uh you know was was and then they've
kind of gotten subsumed so it has
happened on on both sides right and so i
so my argument and this is where i think
we're gonna fight right um is that first
of all on the republican side that was
the mistake that never trump republicans
made
instead of going out there and and doing
sort of you know defending democracy
they needed to just do democracy they
needed to go and create a faction inside
the republican party of those people who
were sort of free market national
security whatever they were the old form
republicans who were strong enough and
organized enough that these new
populists had to negotiate with them and
the same thing and again this is where i
would say
to you right that that's where the
opening is in the democratic party right
that is we have a dsa kind of wing now
they're out there we have a faction
there right right now the mainstream
biden
pelosi
you know clyburn kind of part of the
party only has to negotiate with them
right they're the only organized
alternative inside the democratic party
and unless there's what i would call a
sort of radical liberal andrew yang
wing also in the democratic party that
those mainstream have to negotiate with
then again the path of least resistance
you've seen this in the biden
administration is just to gradually keep
getting
pulled to the left and so part of the
argument is that a i think we have a way
to get some of the benefits of
multi-partyism
in our two-party system right that's a
historical way we know we have a
template we have a program we know how
to do that on the republican side i
think the major problem there are a
couple of things that i think make this
very difficult because like i know a
bunch of the
i consider them let's say moderate
republicans who are not trump fans
um and and the problem is that they just
get drummed out of office if they
if
they stand up
and found trump you have like a
diminishing number of folks who are in
that wing of the party
uh
that they're i mean they're subject to
personal pressures
as well
uh death threats really is what i'm
describing when i say personal pressures
i mean i would love it if there was like
a coherent cohesive let's say mitt
romney-led
a faction of the republican party that
was like a counterweight to trumpism
and there were a bunch of people that
have hoped for that for quite some time
but i feel like their hopes have been
dropping every month since
2016.
right but i think the point is that's
because they don't have power right
again these people were used to the idea
that they were the natural
people to run the republican party right
they you know they were like in uh you
know in sort of slightly pretentious
terms they were the onlsion regime right
and they got pushed out by this new
trumpet side so they weren't used to the
idea that they had to organize
themselves in order to protect their own
interest and again that's where that's
what they needed to be doing the day
after trump was elected is starting to
create all of those
same structures again the same things
that those dsa people did right they had
the right idea of how you actually
practiced them
the problem on that side is that you
have these primary voters
and i don't think that this moderate
wing
can win a primary
side you know you had certainly the the
never trump figure in ohio dolan i think
he got about 23 of the vote um so that's
like a sign and he was like the move on
from trump wing um and i think that's
fairly typical like the the the person
who stands up and says like hey enough
of this trump stuff let's like you know
uh go back to basics or be what you
consider a classic republican probably
can get like 20 to 30 percent of primary
voters um which isn't going to be enough
for them to to win and so it seems
professionally
uh self-destructive um so they so no one
does it because you know who wants to do
something professionally self-destructed
right but again i think you're just
redescribing the underlying problem
right the underlying problem is unless
you actually have an organized faction
that can provide money that can provide
ideas right one other thing is just
being against trump is not enough right
that's what voter and just saying we
want to go back to the way things are is
not enough because voters don't want to
go back to the thing the way things were
they don't want a restoration of the
onstage regime right and that's where
again i think there's been a failure of
ideas you know what i'm i'm actually
going to agree with you on this stephen
i think you and i actually see eye to
eye because i agree that that group of
republicans should have
um ideas and policies and principles
that are not like hey not this guy
because that's not really that
compelling
and those principles ideally would be
taken from the niskanen center's
research being like okay you guys are
pissed off you know i get it it's
because the economy has been rigged
against you and here are all the ways
we're going to unrig it uh you know like
like that would be compelling
so i agree with you that they should do
that though maybe the reason why i
differ from you in terms of the approach
is i i think that structurally the way
like this republican primary is set up
is that
you know that that it's not gonna
i mean they haven't tried it to the
extent that you and i are describing so
you know maybe it could do better than
23 percent um but i think that this
party primary is just very very
distorting um that there are these these
things that make it so that you wind up
with like the tail wagging the dog or
this relatively small component of
voters controlling and hijacking the
agenda
yeah and look i mean i totally i think a
lot of our again the disagreement that i
have with you and with lee
is not if i was starting the whole thing
from scratch
what i would create right in fact i
actually think there's a good argument
that our system of
separation of powers right is designed
around not having
dominant parties that control the agenda
right if you go back and you read the
federalist papers right they are
saying that essentially what they want
is a system um based on deliberation
right and that you need
conflict for that and you need to not
have one you know one thing that can
sort of monopolize the agenda in a way
that parties often do right now
the question is so again i think you'd
have more of that kind of deliberation
if um one party couldn't control the
entire agenda and essentially had to
enter into a coalition with other
parties now the difference i have is
there's no way to get there from here
right one so one there's no way to get
there from here right so
and that a factionalized party system
where you have these in a way parties
inside parties
is the best thing we can get that you
can actually get to
reasonably from here and the other thing
is
in spending all your time
trying to actually create to get to a
multi-party system
you're also right time is is there's
simply opportunity cost you're doing one
thing you're not doing something else if
you're not spending your time building
power inside parties where you will be
if you put in a little bit of energy
you'll at least get some marginal
results and in many cases you don't need
that much in order to force the the
dominant part of the party to have to
deal with you on things like rules and
agendas and everything else right even a
little bit of work on building a party
faction can be enough to get you pivotal
power you spend all your time trying to
create a third party then what happens
is you essentially get nothing and
nothing and nothing until you get
everything and i worry that a lot of
people who are being who are being
encouraged to go into third partyism are
being pushed into a thing that won't
actually get them anything and they
could have been using their energy
inside the parties to build power in a
way that would actually get them a lot
of what they want and what you and i
both want so if someone says to me hey i
want to try and invest energy
on in
uh helping
reform or move or catalyze either the
republican party of the democratic party
in a particular way
i applaud it i say like fantastic
uh you know um so i don't think you and
i disagree it's like when i see those
efforts i myself try and help for
example
you know moderate republicans who i
think are trying to do positive things
like uh or
um
people in the democratic party who i
think are pushing in the right direction
um i have like a sense that
like i personally don't think that those
efforts are going to be successful
like i i
i give people all the credit in the
world i'm like go for it but um you know
like i i feel like the
um
the
primary voters uh let's say i mean i'll
just say in the republican party um like
i don't think they'll be buying other
stuff in the timeframe that we have
um and even if you did have a faction
within those parties like i'm not
convinced that they were gonna result in
any of like the bigger bolder changes
that you're describing because at this
point neither party will work with the
other party
and even if you had one party for a
moment saying you know what i would
consider a carbon tax or i'd consider
that neither party can achieve a genuine
governing majority
um
really in this system as it currently
stands um and their political incentives
are not such that they'll pay a price
for not solving a problem um and so
you know what you'd look forward to is
you look forward to
like even if you had like a slightly
more rational republican party which by
the way i'm totally for
like or slightly more
um
i don't know like i mean the democratic
party i think really has at least two
parties within its confines and you
could say it's great that they're like
negotiating but like you know it's like
i'm but i like i don't think that either
side and that you this two-party system
is going to be able to achieve anything
meaningful
uh for any long-lasting period of time
okay so i agree with that but i think
the implication is somewhat different
than you suggest right so my theory
essentially is that
a faction in either party let's take the
democrats because i'm a democrat and i
think basically you're a democrat so i'm
just gonna say i think that's basically
where you are right
it only has to be big enough that the
whole rest of the party can't govern
without it right and that it can
withhold withhold its support from that
party if it doesn't get what it wants
right so right now right anybody right
joe manchin is a faction of his own
right he can just stand up and they
can't do anything without him right
imagine if you had a group of democrats
who was just five senators right five
senators could at the beginning of a uh
of a legislative session say you know
we're not going to support whoever it is
for majority leader unless they agree to
rules that make it much easier
for people in the parties to put things
on the agenda right like a carbon tax or
whatever it else it is right because
right now the problem is
either party when they're in control
only allow things on the agenda for the
most part where their parties are
entirely unanimous and they're opposed
to the other party right
once you break that once you have a
small enough faction that can say we
don't want to have rules like that
anymore we want to have more of a
free-for-all in determining what are we
talking about once you have that once
you have those new rules then people are
going to sit around and say you know
there are coalitions to be made with the
other party we could be talking about
something completely different than
either one of the parties want to talk
about right and that's where again i
think just building that pivotal power
inside parties can get you a lot of that
loosening up of the agenda that can
allow for a lot of new things to happen
and again it just going back to the
captured economy point
if you want to break any of these um
these existing status quo it turns out
that the status quo has supporters in
both parties right but so does it have
opponents right if you want to actually
get a large enough majority to do
anything about these things you need to
be able to pull people from both parties
and therefore you need to break the
party's
leadership's dominance over the agenda
and that's what i think even a
relatively small
faction of people who have a different
orientation could do and that's where i
see that is an opportunity again
every little bit you get gets you a
little bit more of that pivotal power in
a way that trying to change the entire
electoral system again gets you nothing
until it gets you everything and maybe
not get you anything because you may
never get you may never win and that's
where i think that scarce power you've
got is better put into
[Music]
that i actually like the
characterization of you get nothing
until you get everything because like i
i see
uh i see a realignment as completely
feasible uh pretty quickly and one thing
i'll suggest as like a very low-hanging
fruit opportunity for let's say a third
party
there are over a half a million elected
offices around the country including
many that are unpaid non-partisan
county executive state rep city council
type positions
you know can you get
hundreds maybe even thousands of uh
local office holders under the ford
party in like you know
six years like uh if you have the
resources i think you can uh and
do you think that there is even a bigger
realignment possible the national level
given that uh
frankly like the
enthusiasm for both parties at a record
low and 62 percent of americans want to
move on from the two-party system and 50
self-identify as independents i mean
heck even having evan mcmullen in the
senate as an independent like he could
be a one-person faction what you're
describing you know you can do it from
within the party system i applaud the
people that try but i think the entire
party system is well overdue
uh you know and it sounds like you and i
agree where if you had a magic wand
you're like yeah i never would have
designed it this way because this is
poor design
[Laughter]
you know it sounds like you and i have
the same goals though like i would
applaud anyone who's trying to do what
you're describing yeah i mean i i so it
may be that i have a um a more tragic
view of the world than an engineer's
view of the world right that i think i
think there are a lot of things that are
unfortunate and we can't do anything
about right and just to go back to the
point about realignments remember we
haven't had a realignment that involved
an actual new party since the 1850s
right but we've had a lot of
realignments since then and most of
those were because of shifts in what you
might think of as factional or
coalitional dynamics right that we had
essentially a realignment in the 50s and
60s as african americans moved out of
the republican party and moved into the
democratic party right that happened
while the two parties were still the two
parties we didn't get you know we had we
had some moments of new parties right
obviously strom thurman ran on a
dixiecrat party george wallace ran on a
uh on a third party but the change
really happened because the
because the forces inside the parties
shifted all right and i think having a
democratic party that had a sort of
market-oriented reformist pro-social
insurance
anti-capture
faction that the whole rest of the party
had to deal with a i think would have a
realigning effect because i think there
are a lot of republicans who would be
more sympathetic to being in a party in
a faction like that who could actually
say and this goes back to your branding
point right they could say oh i'm not
like those aoc democrats i'm a andrew
yang democrat right and that's a faction
it's got a personality and it's got a
program
and it's got a thing you can join you
can actually go somewhere and meet other
people and like huddle together for
warmth um those are all things that i
think would be very powerful and really
could shift around the coalitions and
the parties and would make the
republicans
sufficiently fearful that they were just
going to be in a kind of permanent
minority status that they would have to
worry that just giving over their party
entirely to trumpism was going to was
essentially going to doom it right but
right now you've got all these
republicans who essentially feel like
they're stuck in the republican party
because the democratic party's going and
that's what we have to change like like
if they had a place to go and i know
because i had these conversations with
them all the time and you do too i mean
how many
republicans have said to you it's like i
would love a place to go i mean like
either millions tens of millions um and
to the point you make about look um the
last big realignment was uh you know
abraham lincoln winning as a third party
candidate in 1860 with 39.8 percent of
the vote um and it's been a while and
then in 1964 the parties realigned
because of the civil rights act but then
since 1964 what you've seen is just
increased polarization between the
parties then you have cable news coming
in 1996
with fox and msnbc and then facebook in
2004 so the parties have started to go
like this
and there are billions of dollars
driving them in this direction um and so
if if if in the face of the these
historical trends if the plan is to go
in and try and move this party like back
this way or this party back this way
like uh you know like you're go you're
swimming against like a giant tide um
and
and so this is obviously because you
know i am andrew yang and so like if you
were to say to me like hey your choices
are like try and create the andrew gang
uh like faction of the democrats or
uh like try and energize this unspoken
for
independent voter third party which you
know can
run the gamut in terms of ideology
though i suspect most of them agree with
some of the things you just recommended
i mean like i agree with most all of
them and i am by the way going to
revisit
uh naming this left libertarian
uh like human libertarian kind of strain
that that miss kanan center represents
so i i made uh the choice um and i'm a
hundred percent confident that it's the
right choice um and i can't wait for you
and i to like and continue having these
conversations that we can revisit um
like uh you know what happens but like
as someone who you know actually is
monitoring what's going on with the
forward party and the rest of it uh i'm
i'm really excited about it well again
the only thing i would say is uh i'm not
100
confident that i'm right and neither
should you be right i mean that's i mean
hey nobody who's you know i mean one of
the elements i think is also i have
think of is in andrew yangism right is
sort of uh that kind of rational thought
print or one of the basic rational
thoughts principles is everything is
kind of our bets
you're right in the sense that i don't i
don't live in an alternate reality where
i could see how the engineering democrat
thing is going um but i live in a
reality where i can see how the forward
party thing is going and i'm really
excited about it
again i mean
i'll say is i think you and lee might be
right right there might be a pathway
that i think is low probability but
right lots of low probability bets in
life do pay off right so i think given
you know we've got a lot of history
about
third parties and none of them are good
right but lots of things
nothing happens until it does right so
you might be right and we might come
back in ten years and you'll say hey
steve tell us you and your political
science degree turned out that you were
wrong and i was right right um but i
think my point is about what the balance
of probabilities are i think the balance
of probabilities are to get where we
both want to go right this is the thing
that has the higher probability of
payoff well you and i both want to uh to
get to the same place um would certainly
love to work with you in yours to help
make it happen loved in this canon
center love
your personal research
the arguments you make uh you know i'm
on board with virtually all of them
um and so
you know if anything i feel like i like
i wish that there were people taking on
these problems from multiple angles uh
you know like i'm i'm gonna try
this way that i'm excited about if there
are folks that uh are working within the
parties super supportive and excited
about them um and really congrats to you
for joining this effort and helping
inform people
uh i think your ideas are super
important um and uh you know keep them
coming because and send them my way
because like i'll do my best to help get
them out out there
yeah and thank you and your listeners
right they're all up there in the
niskanencenter.org so go and check them
out
yeah is there anything that people can
do aside from maybe buy one or two of
your books
uh well they should certainly do do that
um i mean one thing i've been thinking a
lot is i do think there are a lot of
people like us right who have that you
know who feel like they have this sort
of synthesis of ideas but don't know
what to do with it right they don't know
where to join right like i would take
the example i think there's lots of
college students who are somewhere in
our space right they want something that
doesn't seem to be either the
traditional left or right but they're
also bored by sort of what we think of
as traditional centrism and so i think
the niskanen center is a natural place
they should create niskanen center
chapters on their university campus they
should sit around they should invite us
to give talks they should um you know
sit around have reading groups of our
stuff right that's you know i'm a
student of the conservative movement
that's my real job right and that's how
the conservatives built themselves right
they built themselves up from chapters
that connected people to each other
where they were they you know where they
got new ideas they then found donors who
were associated with it interests that
were associated right that's how social
movements get created and the most
important thing is for people to get up
off their couch and find other people
who agree with them and work with them
and talk to them and uh and see where
and then join your thing or my thing or
one of these other elements
that's a fine message steven i i i love
it no i i do think like i'm genuinely
going to engage with some kind of
branding exercise
um because i think that this kanan
center is
spot on in terms of like the true
problems and the real solutions they
just don't fall in a traditional left
right spectrum
um
uh so we need to give it a catchy name
and then explain it to people powerfully
and then start the college chapter as
you're describing and everything else um
but to the extent that there is an
ideology that the forward party most
closely resembles uh i think it is
uh
what you all are trying to make happen
every day
all right well that that's great let's
work together
fantastic thank you so much stephen
thank you andrew
[Music]
you